obvious there a way to make potatoes
healthy uh what do you mean like
potatoes are healthy
potatoes have gone some bad reputation
they're actually rich in fiber vitamin C
and potassium but I'm going to show you
how to make my family's Fair way to eat
them let's do it step one cook some baby
potatoes until they're just for tender
best part get out some frustration
coat the pan in some oil and throw down
our smashed potatoes
give them a little flip and let's cook
on the other side these are Perfection
all on their own but if you want to
upgrade we add a little dollop of some
sour cream a little rosette of some
smoked salmon and then garnish with some
chives see Brody potatoes are inherently
Perfection all on their own but with
just two easy ingredients we've got a
hunger crushing combo